>> Tucker: EVER SINCE HE
BEGAN HIS EFFORT TO BUY THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION,
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG HAS BEEN
ATTACKED BY ALL SIDES FOR
THE STOP AND FRISK POLICIES
HE USED FOR 12 YEARS AS
MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY.
UNDER THOSE POLICIES, POLICE
WERE ENCOURAGED TO STOP AND
QUESTION INDIVIDUALS ON THE
STREETS OF NEW YORK AND THEN
FRISK THEM IF THEY SUSPECTED
THEM OF COMMITTING CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
BLOOMBERG HIMSELF HAS
APOLOGIZED FOR ALL OF THIS.
HE SAYS HE IS EMBARRASSED BY
THE EXISTENCE OF THE POLICY.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND ITS
MANY SURROGATES HAVE JOINED
HIM IN THAT THEY HAVE
PARTNERED WITH THE LEFT TO
CALL BLOOMBERG A RACIST FOR
STOP AND FRISK.
THAT’S STAWNDABLE, OF
COURSE, IT’S ELECTION SEASON
AND EVERY POLITICIAN AND
CAMPAIGN KNOW IT’S USEFUL TO
ATTACK AN OPPONENT WHERE IS
HE VULNERABLE.
BUT LET’S TAKE THREE STEPS
BACK.
POLITICS ASIDE, THE ONLY
PROBLEM BLOOMBERG HAS WITH
STOP AND FRISK IS THAT HE IS
APOLOGIZING FOR IT.
STOP AND FRISK ISN’T RACIST.
EVEN AS CRIME FELL IN THE
CITY THE MOST DANGEROUS PART
OF NEW YORK YOUNG MEN MANY
GANG MEMBERS CARRYING GUNS.
STOP AND FRIIVELG FOUND
THOSE GUNS BY THE THOUSANDS
WHILE GANG MEMBERS LEARNED
TO LEAVE THEIR ILLEGAL
WEAPONS AT HOME IF THEY
DIDN’T WANT TO GO TO JAIL.
FOUND ILLEGAL DRUGS AS WELL
AS TOOK THEM AND THEIR
DEALERS OFF THE STREET DID.
MOST SEARCHES DISCOVER A
CRIME NO THEY DIDN’T.
12% OF ALL STOP AND FRISK
SEVERANCE THE FRISK PART DID
DISCOVER A CRIME.
THAT’S REMARKABLE NUMBER FOR
OTHERWISE HARMLESS SEARCH.
IMAGINE IN ALL 12% OF ALL
TSA SEARCHES DISCOVERED A
GUN OR BOMB OR OTHER
CRIMINAL BEHAVIORS.
WOULD YOU WANT TSA ABOLISHED
ASWASTEFUL AND EXCESSIVE NO,
IT’S A HUGE SUCCESS.
UNLIKE AL SHARPTON AND THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT
OF THE NEW BAIL LAW IN NEW
YORK OR THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM BILL WE ARE ALL
SUPPOSED TO LIKE, STOP AND
FRISK ACTUALLY SAVED LIVES,
HUNDREDS OF LIVES, THOSE
LIVES ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
YOUNG BLACK AND HISPANIC
PEOPLE.
IN 1990, NEW YORK CITY HAD
MORE THAN 2,200 MURDERS.
THAT’S A LOT.
THE YEAR RUDY GIULIANI LEFT
OFFICE, THERE WERE 649
MURDERS.
UNDER MAYOR MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG THAT NUMBER WAS
CUT IN HALF AGAIN.
IT DROPPED TO 322 MURDERS.
A YEAR IN A CITY OF
8 MILLION.
SO NEW YORK WASN’T JUST
SAFER, IT WAS THE SINGLE
SAFEST MAJOR CITY IN
AMERICA.
MAYBE IN THE WORLD OUTSIDE
TOKYO.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHO AGREED
WITH THAT?
DONALD TRUMP.
JUST FOUR YEARS AGO IN A
DEBATE WITH HILLARY CLINTON,
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP SAID
THIS:  IN NEW YORK CITY STOP
AND FRISK, WE HAD 2,200
MURDERS AND STOP AND FRISK
BROUGHT IT DOWN TO 500
MURDERS.
500 MURDERS IS A LOT OF
HARD TO BELIEVE.
500 IS LIKE SUPPOSED TO BE
GOOD.
BUT WE WENT FROM 2200 TO
500.
AND IT WAS CONTINUED ON BY
MAYOR BLOOMBERG AND IT WAS
TERMINATED BY CURRENT MAYOR.
BUT STOP AND FRISK HAD A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE
SAFETY OF NEW YORK CITY,
TREMENDOUS BEYOND BELIEF.
SO WHEN YOU SAY IT HAS NO
IMPACT, IT REALLY DID.
IT HAD A VERY, VERY BIG
IMPACT.
>> Tucker: IT’S SO FUNNY
BECAUSE THE ESSENCE OF STOP
AND FRISK WAS TAKING ILLEGAL
GUNS OFF THE STREET
SOMETHING DEMOCRATS SAY THEY
ARE FOR.
NOW THEY JUST WANT TO TAKE
YOUR GUNS OUT OF YOUR CLOSET
BECAUSE YOU DIDN’T VOTE FOR
THEM.
IN TRUMP’S REPUBLICAN
CONVENTION SPEECH LATER IN
2016 HE LAID OUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ROLLING BACK
EFFECTIVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POLICIES LIKE STOP AND
FRISK.
>> DECADES OF PROGRESS MADE
IN BRINGING DOWN CRIME ARE
NOW BEING REVERSED BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION’S ROLL BACK
OF CRIMINAL ENFORCEMENT.
IN THIS RACE, FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE, I AM THE LAW AND
ORDER CANDIDATE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: MAN WAS THAT
TRUE.
NOTHING EFFECTS THE LIVES OF
NORMAL PEOPLE, PEOPLE
WITHOUT POWER MORE THAN HIGH
CRIME RATES.
AND IF YOU HAVEN’T LIVED IT,
SAY A PRAYER YOU NEVER HAVE
TO BECAUSE IT’S THE WORSE
THING YOU CAN IMAGINE.
IN 2016 DONALD TRUMP
UNDERSTOOD THAT HE DIDN’T
CARE ABOUT SNEERING ELITES
IN GATED COMMUNITIES CALLING
THEM RACIST.
HE STOOD BEHIND LAW AND
ORDER POLICIES THAT STOOD
EVERYONE ALL BACKGROUND
ETHNICITIES AND COLORS AND
IT WORKED.
TRUMP DID BETTER WITH MITT
ROMNEY DID WITH BLACK AND
HISPANIC VOTERS.
THAT’S PART OF THE REASON.
THAT COULD HAPPEN AGAIN, BY
THE WAY.
BLOOMBERG IS ON APOLOGY TOUR
BECAUSE HE THINKS HE HAS TO
SAY IT BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
WIN NONWHITE VOTERS.
APPARENTLY HE HASN’T LOOKED
AT THE REAL NUMBERS.
DATA FOR PROGRESS POLLED
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS ABOUT
THEIR FEELINGS ON MIKE
BLOOMBERG.
WHEN THEY BROUGHT UP THE
QUESTION OF STOP AND FRISK,
THE ONLY GROUP THAT DIDN’T
LIKE IT WAS WHITE DEMOCRATS.
BLACK DEMOCRATS FELT THE
SAME ABOUT BLOOMBERG.
HISPANIC AND ASIAN DEMOCRATS
SAID THEY WERE MORE LIKELY
TO VOTE FOR MIKE BLOOMBERG
AFTER HEARING ABOUT STOP AND
FRISK.
IT’S SURPRISING.
NOBODY IN AMERICA OF ALL
RACES LIKE CRIME.
EVERYONE WANTS TO LESSEN IT.
ONLY PEOPLE WHO FEEL
DIFFERENTLY ARE WHITE
LIBERALS.
WHY ARE THEY BOSSING US
AROUND?
WE SHOULDN’T LET THEM.
FOR SOME REASON THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS LETTING
THEM DO THAT ACHE SAID STOP
AND FRISK TO THE LEFT.
WHERE IS THIS GOING EXACTLY?
FOUR YEARS NOW REPUBLICANS
DENOUNCING BANS ON PUBLIC
DEFECATION ON DECENCY?
ALL DESERVE TO LIVE IN A
SAFE CLEAN LAW ABIDING
COUNTRY.
ANY REASON TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN IS BECAUSE THEY
STAND UP FOR THAT WHEN THEY